hello everyone
i did not make this video when this news
came out on may 19 2022
because i wanted to like let the team
who did majority of this have it or all
of it really
um
and let place in playstation have their
pr cycle before i jump in and talk about
it just because i'm excited about it
it'll like make it
about me initially
fine with it now
uh obviously not too much that i can say
i just wanted to share this because i'm
really excited about it and really proud
of everybody that i work with so the
accessibility features for god of war
ragnarok were revealed on global
accessibility awareness day which is may
19 this year
obviously accessibility is something
that i care about a whole lot and i made
that very broadly known the second that
i started working for a playstation
studio um i helped to write this blog
post it was actually largely written by
mila who is the head of the ux team at
santa monica studio they are so
wonderful
um so fantastic to work with i really
just edited it um
but that means i wrote like some
sentences from scratch which is
kind of cool like that's such a small
thing in the grand scheme of things are
very cool for me personally because it
goes from like
having read every uh pr
press release at playstation
uh as a fan to then reporting on them
for ign to then actually writing one of
them
and i actually had input on some
features i pitched
some of the accessibility features in
pretty lengthy detail
and was also
very vocal about wanting the
accessibility features to be revealed
ahead of launch um
but in such a minor way like again i
don't want to take that away from the
team who actually did bulk of the work
they already were very passionate about
accessibility before i joined santa
monica studios something that i
obviously cared about from the gate um
but it was already all there from other
people 100
uh but still very very proud i think the
team has done an incredible job one of
the most successful video games ever
made
um
and they care so so so much and the able
it playstation organization which is an
organization that does these
courses um and has a lot of meetings
that i attend
to make sure that people at playstation
you know know a lot about accessibility
it's all just it's so cool um i don't
want to talk about it too much i just
wanted to highlight some of these
features and um give you guys
the news i guess so
santa monica studio that's me slash us
highlights a selection of the game 60
plus accessibility options designed to
suit players needs so this doesn't
actually contain all of them written by
miele who is the lead ux designer at
santa monica studio the prophecy of
ragnarok brings changes to all the
realms and with that we're excited to
announce some new accessibility features
that will be available in god of war
ragnarok not only have we redesigned our
ui to allow for more flexibility and
readability but we have also rebuilt
controller remapping from the ground up
and added more customization to our
combat and interaction systems we have
retained all of our accessibility
features from 2018's god of war and
expanded upon them to include more than
60 ways to adjust gameplay to build your
style and needs here's a selection of
some new and notable features it's
really weird to read this
when i'm so used to reading news um on a
playstation blog and it's something that
i wrote
again mostly miele but i did have a very
big hand in writing all of the sentences
uh it's cool
um
go to what 2018 pc features are being
added to god of war ragnarok so this is
something a lot of people will already
be familiar with and that is
uh forgotten 2018 on pc we made sure to
improve and continue to iterate on
popular features from the initial
playstation release we're pleased to be
continuing the support of these features
in goto 4 ragnarok on ps4 and ps5
sprint slash auto sprint
you'll sprint while the stick is held
and uh stop when released um
it's fantastic when auto sprint is
active you can begin sprinting by
pressing the move stick forward for a
short period of time in one direction
duration required to engage the audio
sprint is configurable by you persistent
dot always on radical if you need
additional focus points to reduce motion
sickness which is something that is
super important to a lot of people
or just want a persistent reminder of
the center of the screen we offer the
ability to turn on a center dot in three
different sizes and seven different
colors aim style you can choose either
hold or toggle on slash off the aim
stance block style you can choose to
hold on or off the shield stance
new to god of war
ragnarok subtitle and caption
improvements
so important for so many players and
also actually pretty difficult um
a pretty interesting ui challenge for a
lot of studios
we have heavily invested in proving
improving our subtitle and caption
system to allow for even more
customization and information like this
stuff
the direction indicators are
super cool it's showing you exactly
where the sound is coming from in the ui
so cool subtitle in caption size we have
increased our minimum text size which
again so helpful for so many people
across so many games so many games have
really really really small text even for
a person who doesn't have any visual
impairment um just sitting too far from
a tv it can be impossible to read
uh add a new scaling this includes an
extra large text size to make subtitles
and captions more readable we have also
dedicated a larger text area to match tv
and movie subtitle standards
you can change subtitle and caption
colors
adjust color speaker name subtitle body
and captions individually you'll be able
to choose between seven different colors
then speaker names which is a retained
option from 2018
you can show a hide speaker names you
can set the size independent from the ui
text size
captions with expanded sound effect
captions
we've added several new ways to
understand in-game sound we've added
captions to both cinematics and gameplay
to provide a rich understanding of the
soundscape of the world
really wonderful people who are deaf or
hard of hearing
obviously
you can also enable captions for
critical gameplay information to assist
with puzzles or narrative understanding
stuff like that is like for example
you'd be able to tell where a certain
noise came from and what the noise was
so that you could figure out where you
had to have to go to find it
subtitle and caption at background blur
included options to allow for blurring
the complex
what do they have complex from out there
to allow for blurring the background
behind subtitles and captions to make
them more readable over complex scenes
and subtitle background is retained for
2018 as well
direction indicator again sort of
highlighted up here
i think is so cool
um
critical gameplay sounds now have an
optional direction indicator which shows
the direction a sound is coming from to
assist with puzzles that have sound cues
this indicator will help to orient
towards the source of an important
sounds kind of what i was touching on
earlier
very cool text and icon size is bigger
obviously screenshots of the ui showing
that which is the best
controller remapping
you love to see it this is so important
to me um
and in my
time playing and i play it controller uh
remapped um
it's awesome
uh we have rebuilt our controller
remapping system to allow you to
customize your button configurations in
god of war ragnarok there'll be a wide
range of preset layouts as well as
custom controller relapping support
individual buttons can be swapped and
for complex select complex actions you
can choose alternate configurations from
preset list
i for the record just in case it's
coming across weird i'm trying not to
elaborate on these things while i could
elaborate on all of them and give you
examples i don't want to do that because
what sony has approved is what is in
this
so while i could elaborate on all of it
i keep catching myself and going i can't
um i just want to be respectful
my job is more important than making
content so uh
if that is coming across at all that's
my bad um yeah i can't give you any more
information then what has they publicly
approved us to say
we offer multiple ways for you to
customize your experience for certain
actions that require more than one
button including touchpad shortcuts for
things like spartan rage navigation
assist and quick turn all of which is
very cool and very important to me
personally
um it's some of the stuff that i had him
put on
mostly not again mostly everybody else
high contrast mode our new high contrast
color mode allows you apply a color to
objects in game like targets enemies and
other characters in addition to a
variety of item types when active this
will apply a color layer to characters
that will make them more visible against
the background you can optionally
desaturate the background to further
increase the contrast traversal paint
loot items and special effects can also
be made more visible in this mode and
that's obviously the example they use
with freya and kratos there uh hi
contrast activation customization select
off on or always on for gameplay this
will exclude cinematics
um
high contrast mode can be set to toggle
on and off for a swipe for easy access
which is really cool
this mode will automatically disable 1a
settings when in a settings menu or
character menu high contrast color
customization you can select the color
palette that fits your play style and
adjust individual colors for characters
enemies and items then you've got your
their companion character as yellow
hi contrast background customization
separately select mid tone or darken
background contrast levels
navigation assist
this is so cool it's so cool
i love it i use it all the time
navigation assist um this camera
navigation system allows you to orient
your view towards your compass objective
nah when in combat pressing navigation
button will orient your view in the
direction of the next story goal um
i feel like i can probably like
elaborate on that a tiny bit it's
basically
it just
you'll press
the button
and then the camera will turn you
towards uh
what your next objective is um so that
you
have assistance when navigating it's
it's great it's awesome
uh traversal assistance gap jumping
vaulting mantling and other traversal
features can now be automated based on
the direction you press and assistance
plus adds interaction based move like
climb scrolls and squeeze through
also very cool
audio cues we have a link to sound q to
each of the on-screen interact prompts
so that when using this feature you can
hear what an interact icon is nearby as
well as the button when the button
prompt uh becomes active audio queues
extend to additional combat cues like
unblockable attack rings targeting aim
cues and weapon swap cues the volume of
audio queues can be adjusted separately
from other volume sliders so you can
adjust it for your own comfort
uh god of war ragnarok reveal trailer
there is an audio described version to
celebrate global accessibility awareness
day we also wanted to provide an audio
described version of the god of war
ragnarok reveal trailer that came out
last year and in the end uh more to come
we hope you've enjoyed a look into the
section of 60 plus accessibility
features that will be included in
carnival ragnarok again there are many
more to come
we are committed to improving
accessibility and customization for
everyone and i can tell you firsthand
that i have never read a true statement
um the team really really really cares
the team who's working this is so
passionate about it it's such a core of
what they do i was so impressed and
i feel so lucky to be working with them
and to know them they're just really
good people um
who just really get it and
yeah i'm just
i don't know i just think they're so
awesome
it's so cool um
to have people who really do care that's
not just words that's not just pr like
they're so passionate about this that
it was so so so important that god of
war ragnarok was as accessible as
humanly possible
at this point in time um it also says we
can't wait to tell you
details about our other categories of
accessibility features like combat slash
aim assist such share
[Music]
we can't subscribe to share more with
you as we get closer to launch happy
global accessibility awareness day and
then i thought i'm gonna watch this
trailer here's the audio accessible
version logo playstation studios
a blizzard outside a dark cave snow
whites out the entrance kratos dark
beard bald head ash white skin and a red
facial tattoo is seeded by a fire making
arrows
he wears a heavy fur cloak and leather
armor it's really cool tech atreus a
teenager yellow tunic and leather
hunting armor approaches carrying a deer
he presents the deer to his father
i'll leave the link in the description
if you want to check it out you get the
idea but but yeah i um
i just wanted to
to share to make sure that this has as
many eyes on it as possible
because i think it's really cool and i'm
just so
proud
of
to know the people who did majority of
it and
know how much they care and and know how
important it is that they've executed on
so many of the things that they have and
that they've done such an incredible job
of doing it i just
it's the best